the school-to-prison pipeline it's a
term that describes how American kids
get pushed out of public schools and
into the juvenile and criminal justice
systems basically harsh zero-tolerance
policies and schools have led to more
suspensions expulsions and even in
school arrests getting suspended or
expelled means more time away from
school and it doesn't take an honor
student to figure out that's bad news
in fact expelled and suspended students
are more likely to get held back a grade
end up in juvie or just drop out
altogether and dropping out of high
school makes you three times more likely
to get arrested back in school forget
about hallway monitors students these
days often have to deal with school
police minor offenses that might have
landed you in the principal's office
back in the day can now actually lead to
your arrest students of color and those
with disabilities are disproportionately
affected black students get expelled
three times more than their white
classmates while a student with a
disability is two times more likely to
get an out-of-school suspension than
everyone else and it's not because these
kids are just bad apples the Justice
Department found that black students got
harsher punishments than their white
peers for doing the same things so maybe
it's time our education system got
schooled